vous avez bien joué au bingo, est-ce que j'ai l'air de
jouer au bingo une gazelle en
particulier même si elle fait de mauvaises
choses je suis un grand officier de fan en tant que
personnage vous savez il y a mes
mâchoires de petits boulots et à l'origine dans la bande dessinée
qui nous avons fait  faites-en un mec et j'ai dit que je
pensais que vous saviez ce que nous pourrions faire de cela
assez sexy et élégant et si vous avez un
blaze comme ça, vous n'avez pas besoin d'être
fort, vous devez juste être agile et
précis qui elle était et quelqu'un
m'a montré sa vidéo de danse Nike comme vous pouvez
tordre et retourner et tout et j'ai pensé
qu'elle avait un super look et je l'ai rencontrée
et elle a eu une bonne lecture et a obtenu le
rôle s'il l'a fait ouais je l'ai tué qui a
tendance à se produire quand vous  tirer sur quelqu'un
dans la tête quand je suis arrivé et je vois Sam
Jackson et Mark Hamill ici et le
désarrangement était mon premier jour de tournage
je ne pouvais pas croire que j'étais là mais pourtant je
devais me concentrer et faire tout le travail vous
savez mais c'était vraiment  passionnant et
c'était tellement intéressant
Mathew m'a expliqué plus de gizelle comme
être vous savez comme une femme très forte
était mortelle
et elle est aussi la main droite de Valentine
et elle est très impliquée dans
le projet et elle est une double amputée
et elle a un très bon accès à ses
jambes ce n'est pas le méchant évident que
vous rencontreriez là-bas  elle est la bonne
assistante et elle est très méticuleuse et
soignée mais elle peut se battre donc c'est un joli
contraste j'aime ça